I'm Joel ipsec I'm a professor in the
department of pathology and also
genetics and biology at Stanford
University I grew up in western
Pennsylvania little steel town all the
steel mills are gone went to college end
up at Oberlin College want to be a poet
so I took a bus Greyhound bus for a few
weeks ended up in San Francisco and try
to make a living as a public not so easy
yeah don't be a poet like that I still
like poetry then I found a job working
in a laboratory and I really fell in
love science I went to UC San Diego and
did an md/phd there and then I got
really excited about cancer research
when these genes called hunka genes were
discovered this was like late 1970s I
ended up training in a laboratory that
was studying some seemingly obscure
viruses that caused cancer in chickens
but it turns out those viruses stole
normal genes or the same inane to cause
cancer in us I'd been trained as a
biochemist someone who purifies proteins
and sort of in the middle of my training
this whole gene thing started people
able to isolate gene sequence jeans and
I was all excited by cancer and so I
wanted to work on when he's oncogene so
it's I've been doing it for 30 years a
long time for the past 20 years I've
been at Stanford i was at UC san diego
and the faculty and at suny stonybrook
in New York and I've run a cancer
biology ph.d program here and I teach
now classes to undergraduates about
cancer of the freshman know nothing
about science and to some science majors
who are want to do science as a career
you